comment vont-ils sous la pluie
j'allais moi le moral il a baissé d'un
coup au ça me manque août écoutez j'ai
vu un truc qui m'a choqué déjà c'est
qu'aujourd'hui à faire un ce bruit dit
qu'on a déjà fait il ya presque trois
ans d'accord ça fait trois ans qu'on
fait un saut au brésil par mois vous
imaginez le nombre de ces mre d'ikea sur
la chaîne aujourd'hui on refait un petit
tour sur le sobre et dit ce seuil il est
génial parce que c'est que des images
quand tu les vois il ya un sens caché tu
fais vous avez plisser les yeux pleins
de fois dans cette vidéo par exemple une
photo de famille arrêter de boire photo
avait été choisi par streaming vous
imaginez ça ceci cela et cela alors est
ce là qu'est ce que vous en faites vous
le classer dans quoi et si on posait à
côté de tous les fleuves conveyor
hollande actuellement comme moi même en
foot sur le toit mais sortez la de la
inscrivait la dea des cours d'escaladé
loin d'ici loin de cette famille et
c'est quoi ça c'est un barbecue c'est
une bombe c'est bon c'était une bonne
intro on est tous dans le bain on est
prêt je pense qu'on a fixés de très
bonnes bases là pour la suite de la
vidéo
[Musique]
j'ai
bas peter parker on n'a pas pu se
procurer le vaccin auprès du shield
j'apprécie le fait que des gens fassent
des blagues au moment des vaccinations
qui sont des moments plutôt chiant 1
globalement voilà lui il a fait l'effort
il s'est mué en spider man j'apprécie
bon assez grande guerre sont derrière
lui mais mais bon bien aux trop mignon
regardez c'est quelqu'un car repeint sa
voiture pour faire genre que c'est sonic
qui court pour faire plaisir aux enfants
du quartier probablement ça marche pas
assez dégueulasse c'est sûr reconstitue
fusil au montage de ce que ça donne ça
ne marche pas j'en suis convaincu
ah ouais non là ouais bon si entre deux
visions tu veux avoir un petit choc
d'endorphines d'adrénaline c'est
forcément fake mais je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai ce truc malsain j'aimerais que ça
ne soit pas le saviez-vous en
vieillissant on se met tous à développer
plus ou moins la peur du vide hélas rien
qu'en voyant cette image je suis pas
bien mon bpa s'affiche à l'écran
alors celle là elle est très connue et
elle n'a jamais marché sur moi
j'aimerais bien savoir le pourcentage de
gens parmi vous susurre qu'elle marche
c'est vraiment la vanne vu et revu je
trouve on devient dur ce qu'on peut se
permettre d'être dur comme ça où est-ce
qu'on est insolent après 2000 ce brésil
quand même on a le droit non
quelques courageux moustiques vient me
piquer soeurette je t'autorise
[Musique]
ça existe ça quel intérêt en plus sur un
jeu mobile il faut aussi le clavier à ce
moment là si tu fais ça donc ça marche
pas l'écran tactile c'est dix fois plus
pratique qu'est ce que c'est que cette
source et les ont dirait une dimension
où toute la high tech a mal tourné et on
et à la souris sur nos téléphones je ne
veux pas de cette dimension laissez-moi
[Musique]
la punition 6 les prendre au bas quelle
bonne idée une souris en forme de
flingues donné là à la meuf de la
dimension alternative là elle se fait
buter par les flics ça c'est quelqu'un
qui a tenté de tuer des gens en sortant
un accessoire soit disant marc en voilà
mais le vrai but c'est que ces gens
meurent à cause d'un quiproquo c'est
évident
j'ai une collection de maneki neko à lui
tout seul il explose ma collection je
veux celui là je suis dégouté je vais
dans ce vote ce truc
pas mal pourquoi je mets un cosplay mon
gosse déjà vous le savez cet été j'ai
fait un beau trip le plus relou c'est
d'aller faire pipi en pleine nuit
franchement ça ça mourir égalé pouvoir
te lever aller chercher un truc dehors
ou quoi sans devoir te rhabiller qu'elle
kiffe
oublier ce que je veux dire il n'y a pas
de zip ici c'est juste ça fait chaud au
bas alors qu'est ce qu'il fait là
j'appelle spa je porte plainte
maltraitance animale c'est pas drôle
tout ça pour des lacs sur une photo
allez vous allez perdre votre chance à
vous faire du bien c'est bien d'avoir
des lacs alors ça c'est trop fort c'est
génial non en vrai ça te fait des
cheveux longs et sa passe crème on
dirait que ses cheveux ça veut dire
qu'elle peut se faire une coupe genre un
carré et à côté de ça sur une coupe
queue de cheval et l'illusion est
parfaite grâce à ça je suis très premier
degré il ya zéro second degré là cette
photo c'est internet j'aimerais
l'appeler internet le combo est dingue
cheveux bleus cosplay carte graphique
dans le sac
o o sache même j'y mets toi je t'invite
à bon halloween et tu viens avec ton
choix tu viens avec ton choix je lui
fais un espace avec du foin avait un
truc dos et tout ramène ton cheval à la
maison ce blé comment vous dire je
comprends pas cette image lâché en mode
écoute et j'en ai vu des projets mais ce
projet ce projet je comprends pas
regardez bien le bonheur que traduit le
visage de la personne à l'intérieur de
cette machine obscures on aimerait tous
être comme alice alors je vais commander
cette machine
la cierva seul en train de se faire
amputer les gars et ça mais mal choisi
stop eux mêmes ils savent qu'elle est
glauque leurs machines ils l'ont mis en
rose pour un truc fancy aaa c'est mignon
regarder non votre machine elle fait
peur aux gogos gadget ou rire nerveux
bien nerveux de cette personne face à ce
qui se passe elle est descendue à la
prochaine station je me dis tout de
suite elle et free roll a qui bossent à
monoprix lidl qui a osé calais sont
quatre heures dans la caisse
qui et qui en plus se faire neuf au plat
pour son quatre heures n'avez vous pas
honte messieurs je m'adresse à vous
pensiez avoir atteint un certain niveau
de brome ans avec vos meilleurs potes là
genre s'est pas vu depuis un moment on
se fait un câlin on a vraiment des
émotions très fortes l'un pour l'autre
on est vraiment très très a mis d'accord
d'accord c'est mignon avez vous déjà
pisser dans le meyrinois
by saison
ça me dégoûte oh non
là c'est pas c'est au nom
je t'aime moi qu il pleuve tu couvres
pas et tu te caches dans des magasins à
c'est trop mignon 16 faudra inventer
faudra inventaire harnais pour chiens ou
tu peux plug dessus injuste aux d'un
parapluie ce serait où ce voit la petite
idée de produit à créer un pour les
épisodes business ma carrière les vidéos
et qui veulent faire faillite
alors l'image ok mais surtout deux
postes d'affilée dont le thème est le
parapluie salle plus bizarre dans
l'histoire
[Musique]
soit c'est ce qu'on pense soit ça n'a
rien à voir et c'est quand même une
énorme erreur imaginez juste marquer 25
et c'est nous les gros d'asie d'ailleurs
ça circule là dedans
waouh au ça va pas du tout cette
vidéo c'est la davie de ma carrière
c'est ça c'est ça le projet des abris
dit par ubisoft
qu'est ce que vous avez fait quand même
vos tassel bug passer plus de temps dans
le développement des choses mais rld a
plus aucun jeta gars d'ubisoft après ce
commentaire c'est bizarre
alors déjà j'adore le fait qu'elle ait
du vernet différents sur chaque mot et
ensuite on peut voir des petites réduire
un peu partout ce qui montre que c'est
une arme en plastique et que c'est donc
une arme vers sauf très premier degré
très chic ans n'a pas bougé d'un one
ça me fait me fait mal au coeur ce team
h on en vient à émuler des anciens
appareils parce qu'il nous manque
profitez de tout l'électronique qui vous
entourent profiter qui seront émules et
bientôt voilà voilà
enfin une qu'a compris fuck you les
parents açores vos enfants sur le genou
d'un inconnu déguisé en père noël pour
les faire kiffer alors qu'ils savent
bien que c'est pas le père noël ça se
voit il est bien trop content pour être
le père m'a même le père noël en aurait
marre des taties dans un sens commercial
une semaine à asseoir vingt mille
enfants par jour sur ses genoux il a des
hématomes sur ses genoux ce monsieur
vous comprenez ça elle en a ras le cul
elle vous l'a fait comprendre j'adopte
cet enfant
c'est moins de gros crocodile je te
laisse base et tagué de base' marge sur
le bon vouloir et moi le gros godillots
c'est un déclin graduel des capacités
mentales et il a mangé comme un damné
moi ce crocodile tout c'est à cause de
lui autant d'espèces en voie de
disparition nous n'a rien fait les
humains promis donner la moindre passe à
wattrelos on n'a rien fait on regardez
la belle phrase de salopards je vais
vous dire cette phrase dans tous les
magazines tous les guides touristiques
le japon se japon à mi chemin entre la
tradition et la beauté germa they kill
bill là ya pas longtemps et c'était
vraiment cool époque des batailles qu'on
n'avait pas encore d'armes à feu
s'étaient quand même c'était quand même
beaucoup ou la cancel une fois de plus
cela dans la vidéo se fait beaucoup aux
îles à encausse mais cheikh aweys ou
d'examens
[Rires]
c'est un peu bâtard ce que je dis c'est
juste par le visage en verre il a
rajouté deux oreilles un peu mal fêté
jeudi son cosplay ouf mais il fait très
chaud est qu'il fait graver shrek irl
j-pal et parce qu'il a l'air d'avoir la
sympathie
voyez ce que je veux dire
[Musique]
ben
alors ferro faut pas voler les cheveux
des gens comme ça tu as demandé aux
combattants
d'un coup peut-être moins au ca tue les
scènes de vie miniature je trouve ça
trop bien et j'aimerais trop en avoir
une chèvre contacter quelqu'un pour en
faire une une demande régulièrement des
news et je sais pas quoi lui faire faire
mais j'aimerais trop en avoir une chez
moi pas celle là tu est une qui donne un
peu plus la joie de vivre
commencez à marans
du coup si du coup si ça marche assez un
faux plafond dans un centre commercial
voir ces les centres commerciaux aux
états unis qui imite un ciel et ouvrir
des lagache de 7 mètres sur 4 c'est
vraiment une belle gâche au nom au nom
c'est pas sympa ça quel kiff au regard
des est-ce que la meuf de thaler aurait
échappé au piège la meuf de thaler elle
a réussi à échapper aux pièges et à se
poser à une cafétéria incroyable je
laime encore plus
[Musique]
pourquoi pas fonction vous voulez si je
dis pourquoi pas kita est mort autant
être amenés à la morgue avec style
ok pardon
arrêtez de vouloir à tout prix amenez
vos enfants devant un faux père noël
regardez merde où j'allais vous l'avez
mis en prison le père noël sérieusement
arrêté
[Musique]
oh mais je dames c'est la fin de ce
merveilleux je me suis régalé j'adore ça
brille dit puisqu'il ya beaucoup de
trucs un peu dark et de trucs très
absurde et c'est tout ce que j'aime
j'espère que ça vous a plu la prochaine
vidéo sera un nouveau concept qu'on
attente et qui était très amusant a
tourné le rendu est vraiment pas mal se
contentera de vous la voyez il ya pas
mal de grosses vidéos qui arrivent là
jusqu'à début novembre no spoil courage
à vous que vous bossiez où que vous
soyez en d'études que vous foutiez rien
courage à vous je me suis régalé
callamand je vais continuer à se coller
chemin sur ce brésil est incroyable ya
tellement nouveau poste jeu sur au
paradis allez prenez soin de vous mais
je laisse prise au jeu blanc voici la
règle vous arrivez pas réceptionné vous
blesse
[Musique]